I just read this
they gave Neil deGrasse Tyson a
late-night talk show wait you mean the
astrophysicist Neil deGrasse Tyson the
astrophysicists yeah he's gonna have a
new show that's called Startalk and it's
gonna be on the National Geographic
Channel oh you're all like yeah now
that's a talk show yeah that's cotton
into my business you know what you think
I don't know it just sort of bothered me
I was getting freaked out about it like
oh no now Neil deGrasse Tyson a
physicist right has a talk show but then
I calmed down a little bit because I
thought who would go work on a show like
that yeah excuse me koni Corning is that
it's my moon my talk show moon moon it
mood why are you in
[Applause]
well I would want to work on Neil
deGrasse Tyson show okay moon that's
absurd first of all that you can talk
second of all you know that you would go
work on his show you're not going
anywhere you got to be loyal to me I
gave you your start I I thought you and
I were friends oh please I mean what do
you even know about me name three of my
craters I you give your craters names
yeah yeah see you know nothing about me
okay that's not true moon I know
everything about you sometimes you
change shape you only come out at night
plus you're responsible for Teen Wolf oh
no stop stop it look look it's nothing
personal Conan I I just think I'd be a
better fit with Neil okay mine what does
Neil deGrasse Tyson know about hosting a
show and if he thinks it's so easy to
walk out in front of a late-night
audience and we're just gonna go nuts if
he come
[Applause]
hi Conan hey moon and three of your
craters Clavius Tycho and Aristotle
nailed it nailed it yeah just to get the
facts straight
the moon changes shape continuously
during the monthly orbit around the
Earth and while it does this it's
visible in the daytime just as often as
it is at night and only a lunatic would
blame Teen Wolf on the moon okay look
I'm sorry you just can't come out here
and take my moon it's not cool well then
Andy maybe you'd like a job on my show
[Applause]
laugh it up everybody no way Andy and I
have been friends for 22 years that guy
and I are thick he's not leaving well I
mean you know you say we're friends but
we barely talk and I think the moon's
got a point what do you even know about
me you're a you're a Pisces wrong
actually Annie's birthday is October
28th which would make him a Scorpio
if you into 2000 year old mythology but
real science
tells us Andi is something much more
Andy may be small in time and space but
he is a universe unto himself comprised
of atoms whose origins can be traced
back to the stars that exploded billions
of years ago scattering the ingredients
for life across our galaxy and beyond
but the cosmos itself Andy is all that
is or ever was or ever will be Andy come
with me
[Applause]
well I guess I should probably get going
too
you
you